greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
today we're going to talk about a
poisonous white berry that apparently
gets people in the mood mistletoe
a mistletoe is neither a missile nor toe
so of what uses it to me I could use
toes that were missiles that way if I
kick someone they would explode as it
stands I only have my heat ray vision
and it dries my eyes out but this
strange plant apparently you hold over
somebody's head and it forces them to
kiss you I can force people to kiss you
with my godlike powers but do you need a
plant for it's not even a sensible plant
it sounds like a sexual harassment suit
waiting to happen if you were invited to
one of my parties and they are quite
epic but you're not on the list and I
hung up a big wad of poison ivy in the
corner what would make you think make up
corner most sensible animals avoid
poison ivy poison oak poison berries
anything beginning with poison like
poison most sensible humans would
logically avoid anything beginning with
missile butts no they get horny and why
does anyone need to follow the orders of
a weed anyway if you want that person
you take them and conquer them and then
enslave them for the rest of their lives
in the matrimony we call marriage you
don't need a berry to tell you how to do
that normally it just takes a few drinks
final summer
mistletoes have no place in this Ionian
People's Republic of Houston toes that
fire missiles though approved deploy
what we don't have those go work on
those and then decline I am General Zod
and you will kneel before me